anyway here with reaction Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett Fox News
great to see you Hi how are you you know
I've known you for what seven eight
years uh hanging out with you this was
the first time a moment ago yeah that
you let me throw one of your footballs
to the crowd
do it again
make it good it was like Brady
by the way if somebody's gonna get
killed catching a football all right but
there's a serious issue here and that is
he did not identify quote the other
crime right now I imagine that there's
recourse for that I imagine at some
point we're gonna probably get a bill of
particulars or something doesn't he have
to name it at some point yeah he does
you're right the sixth amendment it is
therefore facially defective it is uh
deficient on its face and it would be
susceptible to a motion to dismiss I you
know did he sleep through constitutional
law at Harvard where he you know where
he went to I sort of imagined him late
one night in his uh I got to get Trump
what crime what crime and maybe the
janitor popped off and said well don't
say anything
and that's what he did and he had the
audacity to stand up at a news
conference yesterday and he was asked
point blank what fraud what crime what
law did Trump violence I don't have to
say yes he does have to say let me say
one other thing Robert H Jackson the
great Supreme Court Justice former
Attorney General Chief prosecutor at
Nuremberg he said something very
important he said the greatest danger to
justice is an unscrupulous prosecutor
who targets a person and then scours the
law books to find an offense he can pin
on that person and that's what Alvin
Bragg has done let's get Charlie hurt
Charlie let's get your take
yeah well you know it's maximum
absurdity here uh you have a situation
where according to Alvin Bragg Donald
Trump faces 136 years in prison which of
course is more than uh Bernie Madoff uh
served for his crimes
um and uh but you know I have to say you
know what I think is kind of interesting
about it is when you you know I don't
think that this is going to be the only
indictment that Donald Trump faces I
would not be surprised if he doesn't
face two or three more indictments
before the election uh what I love about
this is this is such a circus it's so
absurd it's so ridiculous Alvin Bragg is
so embarrassed himself embarrassed the
the legal profession that it really is
going to I think set the tone for
anything else any of these wacko crazed
lunatic left-wing politicized uh
Democrat DA's want to do to try to
destroy Trump and quite frankly I think
that Trump comes out of this thing
stronger and uh and then goes into
whatever else they throw at him that
much stronger you know when you when you
look at this Tammy and then you see some
of the president's fiercest critics uh
people that are not allies or people
that don't like Donald Trump coming to
his defense that speaks volumes to me
uh it does and it should even they
recognize what this means about the
country but they should have seen it I
contend that this sort of willingness
started with the FBI and the Russia
dossier the moment the federal law
enforcement got away with moving forward
a a fake document that they knew really
wasn't verified lied to the fisa court
and really no one paid any price for
that that's when this legal system
became weaponized against Donald Trump
in particular certainly we know that
often it's weaponized against the
average American and that's why we need
legal reform so this is not a surprise
it is the natural Next Step considering
what we saw at the federal level with
Donald Trump I also think though that
that the dissenters if you will the
resistors who don't like Donald Trump
especially those on the Republican side
have a duty to recognize that it was
their own Trump hatred that made them
blind to this trajectory which many of
us project that we saw all those years
ago that it's really not Donald Trump
it's what this system has become and
what Republicans have allowed Democrats
to get away with for generations and
that's why we have this here right now
to to say Donald Trump is the problem is
the most absurd Dynamic that has been
the big lie and I think the American
people are seeing it the anti-trumper
see that this exposes that fraud to
everyone and that's the biggest thing
they don't like is that they've been
caught looking at Bolton van well said
John Bolton van Jones Mitt Romney Jeb
Bush none of these people even like
Donald Trump I mean it's very clear I
want to ask you about this
um to me when you run to attack or go
after one man Donald Trump one
organization in the Trump organization
and one family the Trump family and by
the way the A.G Leticia James did that
sure and of course Alvin Bragg did that
and Fanny Willis down in Georgia correct
all right isn't that prosecutorial
misconduct isn't this selective uh
prosecution here right but this is New
York a very liberal bar this is the kind
of stuff a lawyer gets disbarred for
well Alan dershowitz I'm going to speak
with him in a minute he doesn't think
Trump can win in New York he thinks he's
going to be found guilty right and
because the only normal people in New
York are in this world
all right
it's in fact
80 85 percent of the people in this
District voted against Donald Trump and
those are the people that will comprise
the jury pool so you on top of that
you've got a biased judge and so the
deck is stacked the fix is in and you
know my objection to this judge in
particular forget about his politics and
the way he has always ruled against
Trump in other trump-related cases this
is a judge who presided over the grand
jury he watched what was unfolding he
saw the indictment as it was being drawn
up now a good objective Fair
conscientious judge would have said
you've got to State a crime this is
defective I won't even allow you to
issue this indictment but this judge
apparently doesn't care and now he is
given Alvin Bragg eight months to try to
figure out a crime but there is none he
can't charge under state law because it
was a federal election he can't charge a
federal campaign violation because he's
a local prosecutor he can't charge
felonies that are federal we only have
about a minute left let me get the same
question to Tammy and to Charlie hurt
and it's and I'll talk to Alan
dershowitz about this Tammy I believe
they're going to start here in New York
then there's a civil case in New York
that's 27 years old about an alleged
sexual assault in a department store
dressing room uh then you've got the
issue in Georgia then you got a special
prosecutor or Council looking into
January 6th and the document issue which
impacts a lot of people I believe
they're going to try and hit him with so
much in terms of legal entanglements
that it's going to be difficult for him
to run for president is that their
strategy throw up throw paper towels wet
paper towels against the wall hope it
sticks sure
well that's what they've always been
willing to do we saw that they were
willing to effectively break the law in
the beginning with the Russia hoax and
the fisa court they're capable of doing
anything they are panicked over Donald
Trump and the fact is is that it is
interestingly making him stronger and
when they I think when the Democrats see
the polls go up some of these things may
be mitigated but it's Overkill and they
just never know when to stop the
American people have got to be in charge
of this and can't let this continue in
this fashion by showing their support
for this man all right you get the last
word go ahead
Charlie well you know it's you know just
don't don't forget these people are the
same people who hired 187 000 IRS agents
and they're not all going after Donald
Trump they're all going after you so
they have to be stopped Charlie hurt
Tommy uh thank you Greg thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else